estamos começando e vamos até o prato
joão neto prato e não como ele não era
que a cisco naldo estão bem com você e
me beija que o médio netapp
é a gente quem quiser me dar um chinelo
uma roupa nova estou aqui à disposição
para aceitar tudo daquela ie tab
brasileiro também as suas expectativas
nesse jogo eu vou ganhar
a claro até porque né deixou conferir se
a área está bom e aí olha vai ser o jogo
hoje por vencer você joga com muita
expectativa a minha expectativa é a
melhor possível a atendeu e nem postado
então ea defesa vai trabalhar bem contra
nós e que ele não esteja longe pois aí o
neto contribui alguma outra pessoa aí a
gente já vamos ganhamos essa galera a
gente vai jogar um vôlei porque quem vai
jogar um golo porque a gente tem que
praticar esporte na nossa vida se não a
gente pode ficar sedentário e sei lá a
gente pode até ficar que nem o lyon
então por isso a gente agora tá fazendo
esportes a exportar de cais começamos
com esportes radicais
[Música]
d
e pra que eu falei foi recorde
esse vai ser bonito ou não ou não
[Música]
a maio
é igual
i
gordinho mais ex do jogo
a brigada taka
esse é o show da noite
olha aí fui mas com a marca que faz de
moleque goleiro renan
o comércio também não foi não
[Música]
o pig assim mas é um ponta da europa
infelizmente a gente não ganhou mas deus
está no comando de tudo e que era muito
importante pra gente eu cara você podia
negócio que a bola do jogo estava nas
suas mãos em que jogou tudo por água
abaixo
então não há qualquer coisa pra gente
sair do meu time que está fora do time
catalão fez nada
agora não faz mais um populacionais que
a corda que eu vou fazer com que vai
andar subir na hora do recreio metade eu
estou pegou um vôo e chutou com o
futebol não era minha intenção cara mas
tocava o culto do mesmo jeito a mais
agita a galera fica um pouco aqui com
com rubens filho roh neto o racha do
vôlei foi muito bom se eles puderam ver
que eu arrasei nas minhas decisões de eu
voltar ficar velho está a ser o dele
poder também né mas eu queria agradecer
e principalmente a rua galera valeu ela
foi a mulher do jogo você fazer força
das mulheres mas só tinha uma certeza
vem dessa menina foi ela que fez a maria
da penha ela viu a amiga dela o nome da
mari e da amiga dela maria da penha
ela falou maria da penha porque eu sei
que eu olhei para as pessoas não batem
mas a gente quer uma coisa só ele é um
fofo nosso aí quem joga bola chegou a
tirar uma foto com a gente mas que tal e
aí como é que uma página com cara é um
brasil e méxico não está aqui com você
está o porquê é eu conhecer vocês por
causa da minha namorada e df mesmo de
hoje penal
alguns de vocês é aquele achei aquele do
jogo agrada também ao de tudo para o
esporte porque senão você vai ficar
assim exatamente eu estava no mundo mas
aí sei lá eu tomei um tombo na minha
vida e comprei o novo sheik da solange
frazão pra ficar sarado e bonito como o
mst e agora a gente vai pra casa como
boi é a galera se vê de hoje foi mais
descontraído resolvi ir lá fazer um
esporte mas é muito tempo que não jogava
bola o fazia vôo e eu queria pedir para
vocês também é você explicar não gostei
porque a força do verão é você ficar
clicando não gostei
quanto mais é um dos vídeos vejo a 20
mil pessoas 40 mil pessoas clicaram
gostei
a vontade de fazer o outro fico mais
motivado então a motivação de vocês é
curtir do facebook rt no twitter só
curtir na foto divulgação o instagram e
também online neste vídeo e cometem o
que está fazendo essa semana santa que
aceitassem uma bosta não está sendo como
a minha
deus te viram o dia 30 o justiceiro tá
mandando beijo abraço pra você
exatamente o preferido já não teria
então clareza e uma piscina do geovane
giovanni kosovo advogado é um pneu é
isso aí valeu galera